all right everyone take a seat wait why
does Justin have a church in his house
what does the cross have a little foot
on it oh that's a T for thorough because
Justin believes in himself so much yes
you can we just go back down to the
living room no there's a lot of bad
stuff in this binder and I don't want
chase to hear now I want to start with
care great yes I've done a lot of bad
things when I was 11 years old I would
get boners in church because one of the
altar boys was super hot so I would just
took my dick up into my belt during
communion Kerry I know which altar boy
and when I was in the eighth grade we
took a class trip to water world and I
purposefully rode the log flume with my
friend Kevin's dad so I could buy the
picture afterwards and masturbate to it
well honey did you hear he died I did
and when I was 23 I worked at a hotel
and Christopher Meloni stayed there and
one day he went out to the pool so I
snuck into his room and smelled his
underwear but then he returned to a
different room so I don't know whose
underwear I smell oh my god Karen let me
cut to the chase oh we should trademark
that my god I meant things I could find
online
you just described three private sad
moments how would I find those things oh
then I'm just kidding
you know what I didn't find anything bad
on you good you can go do your little
play but Karen please have sex I'm
trying I know something bad that I did
online good luck babe that catalogue
from church is always posting photos of
these ducks in our yard so one night I
did have a little glass of wine I
commented enough with the Ducks and then
i unfriended her I already had to change
churches and now I'm so worried it's
gonna ruin Jesus career oh that is
absolutely not in this bike ah every
single thing is here is about Brooke oh
excuse me no my whole thing is smart
young progressive so I don't know what
you think you found but is it mighty
chance nope oh then I'm golden come at
me you use the word retarded on Twitter
no less than 56 times I mean are we sure
that was man your first tweet was
water is retarded come at me well that
was a long time ago now I'm a social
justice warrior people on Twitter always
tell me I'm a classic white feminist
that's not good and we deleted that
account what I also deleted photos of
you from Halloween is Terri Schiavo okay
I went as Terri Schiavo before and then
I happened to pass out at the party okay
should I continue
well if you have anything else let's
talk about your lab journal I don't know
what do you mean he's our brother keep
your voice down
he's been through enough he has a right
to know
no we have to protect him that's what
family does so it's settled we decide
tomorrow
agreed Brian no no you think I want to
say no like some kind of sick freak of
course not but but nothing we decide the
day after tomorrow and finally your
venmo account okay what could I possibly
have done wrong on Ben mouth every time
you pay Carrie for anything you write
that as slamming that puss okay
that's just sibling humor we deleted
that account too and that's it really
I'm okay what karmically you need to do
some soul-searching yeah
optically we're fine okay all right
let's call you and Donnie people this is
gonna be so romantic
hi and Donnie hey chase okay kiss so
tonight we'll start off with Instagram
live and then tomorrow I have you on the
red carpet for the Hot 97's Summer Jam
oh my god I love summer jam okay one
year I got so drunk and I went home with
this guy but I was dating somebody else
and so I waited until he was asleep to
kiss him that way it wasn't cheating
that sexual assault
Oh oh no no you're confused I'm a girl
and he just wasn't awake and I kissed
him so ya know that sexual assault you
know you make a great point in Donnie
and we're gonna take a break and just
think about that okay we're on mute now
so everybody keep smiling and don't move
your lips because this is very bad
am i doing it on my lips moving no I
gotta get this pictures who's not gonna
suck who do I gotta there are no
pictures
did he wake up and fall a report no he
doesn't know like nobody knows Oh
nobody knows okay no we're not fine
young Donnie said it I committed sexual
assault but no one knows but I know and
strong powerful women like me and and
Donnie we don't do stuff like this I
have to go tell him someone DVR Real
Housewives of Atlanta for me
honey I don't think justin has DVR
you